pues sí que está muy buenas tardes un
clima de mucha alegría que se está
viviendo en estos momentos aquí en el
centro de la ciudad de minneapolis
precisamente porque este jurado formado
por 12 personas de mayoría blanca ha
encontrado culpable a derecho vine de
tres cargos esos tres cargos son
asesinato en segundo grado otro por
asesinato en tercer grado y otro por
homicidio en segundo grado derecho bing
como que no tiene antecedentes penales
se enfrentaría a una pena máxima de 12
años y medio por cada uno de los dos
cargos de asesinatos y hasta cuatro años
por el cargo de homicidios sin embargo y
tal y como se había apuntado en un
principio cabe la posibilidad de que si
se encallaba a culpable como así ha sido
pues qué derecho vil pueda apelar la
decisión aquí la gente estaba contenta
satisfecha y también esperanzada porque
creen que ahora sí se va a abrir un
camino para que puedan cambiar las cosas
todos unidos en cuanto a la brutalidad
policial tenemos las primeras reacciones
por ejemplo del gobernador de minnesota
tim world que ha dicho que la lucha no
ha hecho más que comenzar y este ha sido
un pequeño paso para poder encontrar una
solución a esta a esta situación andoni
algo adelantadas recién bueno como
decíamos estás en la ciudad de
minneapolis el epicentro de la atención
por estos momentos así se llevó a cabo
este histórico juicio contanos qué clima
se vive por aquí y qué reacciones se
están viendo
si de hecho a los pocos minutos después
de que se anunciara de que ese jurado
había alcanzado un veredicto muchísima
gente se agolpa dos centenares de
personas se han agolpado en los
alrededores del centro gubernamental
donde se ha llevado a cabo este juicio y
aquí de 100 es específicamente que
estaban contentos satisfechos por cómo
se había llevado a cabo este caso y
también satisfechos porque por fin el
movimiento social estaba teniendo efecto
llevan casi y llevaron casi un año
protestando en las calles de mineápolis
pero también dicen que se ha de dar voz
a todos esos casos que no se pueden
grabar como con el celular como pasó en
el caso de george wright sin embargo la
ciudad continúa en alerta roja se han
desplegado más de 4.000 efectivos de la
guardia nacional ante la posibilidad de
que se produzcan algunos disturbios en
las próximas horas en tanto el
presidente joe biden ha pedido calma a
la población no sólo en mineápolis sino
en todo eeuu
y ver sí muchísimas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde minneapolis
está